[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen
it's with sadness that I just sending to
you a video and I'm not be able to be
present in person actually I
prepared and I've done all the
preparation to come to Madrid but
unfortunately the negotiations of the
cheap act kept me in Strasbourg for
discuss with Parliament and Council so
I'm very sorry for this and I hope you
can understand but what I want to stress
is that we are really
moving on with the objective of 2030 and
the main objective for 2013 when it
comes to connectivity is that every
citizen every citizen every business
should be connected with a very
high-speed connection possibly with
fiber
and that's why for us gigabits
connectivity it's a quintessential
element of a modern society without
gigabit connectivity we cannot support
Innovative digital application and
services we cannot support Industrial
iot
and of course we cannot support
artificial intelligence very high
performance and Quantum Computing so
it's the basics and that's why uh we
also should look at the transformational
networks when it comes to the gigabit
connectivity as a another important
element that shapes our future and what
we see is that networks are becoming
more intelligent
networks are becoming more blended with
Computing and of course with the
software and applications
when we look at mobile the new
generation of mobile communication will
require massive investment in fiber and
desification of antennas our
connectivity infrastructure Maps be
resilient and secure high quality
infrastructure will enable us to
actually seize our future but where do
we stand according to the data we have
56 of the households are covered with
fiber however member states have
enormous differences in coverage level
with more than 90 percent in Romania and
less than 20 percent in Belgium
and only 40 percent of rural areas are
covered with fiber
this data clearly indicates the need of
interesting device investment in fiber
because this is really what we need to
complete digital transformation a
successful one by 2030.
we are certainly aware that there are
many challenges for Network operators
and that's why we have presented on the
23rd of February a compensate package
that supports the rollout of chicabit
networks first of all a regulation which
is called the gigabit infrastructure act
a new recommendation about regulation of
gigabit networks and a consultation
about the future of electronic
communication sector
we hope that this initiative will create
the right environment to stimulate
Investments and to reduce the cost and
delays for deployments of very high
capacity Network
of course we are also trying to put
together what is necessary in terms of
financing we are using all the range of
instruments we have including the
recovery program uh in all other search
programs connect to your facility this
is an array of instruments that really
are
deemed to complement the private
investment which should remain the main
source of investment for networks of the
future
so how we are going to help private
investors in their Endeavor first of all
the gigapit infrastructure actor will
enable faster cheaper and more effective
rollover gigabit networks across the EU
in particular it will Foster fiber
developed in the three ways it will make
compulsory a fiber installation in new
renovated buildings in Synergy will
building renovation waiver for Energy
Efficiency so Greening goes together
with digital it will ensure clear
condition for access to physical
infrastructure
it will promote the coordination of
Civil Works which will we hope reduce
time and cost for development on
Networks
the regulation streamlines uh the
requirements for a single interface to
facilitate permit granting procedures
and also
all the access to information should be
actually a much simpler with Central
points of reference for companies that
want to deploy fiber
the regulation also limits the permit
fees to and the administrative cost in
terms of procedure and actual cost to
the minimum
in our economic study when we drafted
the regulation we have all calculated
that most of the work that today cannot
be done in coordination will be done in
coordination in the future so from an
estimated of 250 000 kilometer a new
fiber today we will double if not tribal
the cases in which
co-investment and Joint employment will
be possible
this will benefit from administrative
simplification
we calculate that I mean from a savings
that we can have directly on the
businesses this will account to several
billion euros in terms of deployment of
the networks
the second initiative it's about the
regulation and it's about a
recommendation director to Regulators
which we will replace the existing
recommendation about next Generation
Networks
this draft gigabit recommendation is now
in consultation with peric and we hope
to receive the opinion back and then to
adopt it quite soon
it will provide guidance to The
Regulators on how to ensure the right
Market condition to enable fast Network
rollout and sustainable competition and
this we think in four ways first it will
reduce deployment cost by promoting
effective access to regulated operators
civil engineering infrastructure
second it will reassure that the risks
are adequately rewarded and will Foster
incentives for Network deployment third
it will allow operator sufficient
flexibility to determine prices for
access to their Network infrastructure
and finally it will provide guidance on
new regulatory tools and feature
introducing the codes such as
co-investment agreements there are not
so many co-investment agreement for the
time being regulatory commitments so
commitment taken by operator and
treatment of all sale only operators and
another very important point is guidance
on the migration to faster network from
copper Network to 4 to fiber networks
the third element of the package is a
broader consultation on the future of
electronic communication sector
we felt that this consultation was
really necessary because as I said at
the beginning networks are changing
the future connectivity is the blend of
transmission storage Computing all
together it's a kind of computing
continuum we are seeing the architecture
of telecommunication networks
transforming
and in the coming years the whole
industry need to undergo a radical shift
and revisit his business models industry
we have to adapt to succeed
we are seeing Telco operator turning
their business from Mere connectivity to
becoming what we call providers on
network as a service
now in this critical moment it's
important that we reflect we actually
seek views and make sure that we
understand well how to shape the
regulatory landscape of the future
one of the important element which has
been very much in a debate in the the
last year or so it's the so-called Fair
contribution to the development of the
networks now this element is covered by
a consultation
and it's about whether whoever benefits
from Telecom Network should actually
contribute to this deployment
uh this is something that it's uh uh as
I said something that is being discussed
everywhere the commission has not taken
any position on this and would like
really now to hear from stakeholder how
they see this particular issue I must
say in general uh the principles that
are being established by the parliament
by Council the European commission when
it comes to the rights of the citizens
established that whoever benefits from
internet in general should also
contribute from it of course there are
different ways of contributing to the
internet deployment and the consultation
should establish whether we have the
right balance whether new forms are
necessary so we really look forward to
hear from you of your thoughts and also
your suggestions on how to make sure
that we all drive towards our ultimate
objective which as I said at the
beginning is have every citizen every
single European citizen connected to a
fiber Network by
2030. many things
foreign
[Music]